[Music]
what effect do you hope your
new book to have
i know that's that might seem like a
lazy question but i'm going to keep it
broad
i'd just be interested to hear your
thoughts
what would what would be success a
successful effect
for this book looking back 12 months
from now 24 months from now well i would
like it would be lovely if it had the
same effect on people as the last book
appeared to have
you know i'm i mean it's comforting to
me to
read through my youtube comments oddly
enough because that isn't generally a
place people would go for comfort
you know untold numbers of people
have said to me in person but
publicly in in that way that
they put their lives together at least
in some ways
and
you talked about victor frankl you know
when i wrote maps of meaning i said well
i was interested in malevolence
i i was deeply affected by
the accounts i'd read of what happened
in the second world war and
in germany and what happened in soviet
union and in china
these horror shows
that characterized the 20th century
constrained malevolence
and so if you study malevolence you
start to understand what the opposite of
that is
the opposite of malevolence is something
like the hero's journey
you know and it's it's easy to be
cynical about that but
well it's not that easy because if
you're cynical about that then you
undermine your own life
and everyone knows this this is the
other thing that's so interesting
everyone knows this
you never teach someone you love to lie
you're always appalled if you have a son
or daughter
you're always appalled if they don't
tell the truth
you know in the deepest part of your
heart
that if you don't tell the truth
the world falls apart
and that's actually true you know i
talked about unearned wisdom
it's it's no trivial matter
to understand that you know dostoevsky
said
everyone is responsible for everything
that happens to
them and everything that happens to
everyone else as well
and you know that's an insane statement
and he was a very extreme person but
it's also
true and i think that's part of what
people
get a glimpse of when they have a
hallucinogenic induced religious
experience it's like
there's a lot more resting on you than
you think
and you know that you don't wake up in
the morning
berating yourself for telling the truth
you wake up at four in the morning
berating yourself for violating your
conscience
you know and classically in in at least
in some strains of christian thinking
conscience is associated with christ or
with the holy spirit it's the
it's the voice of god within and
i'm aware of all the criticisms of ideas
like that but you know it's pretty
it's really something that you can't
control
your conscience so what what is it
exactly
it's not you you're responsible to it
it holds you accountable
it transcends you so what is it
well if you think it's nothing well
violate it for a while and see what
happens
so you know i hope what i wrote in
beyond order is true
you know and if it's true it should do
some good
because what's true does good at least
that's the hope
you